principles in your mind
right
but never fall down on one knee because
there's five other attackers
and when you're down there they can get
you
so don't thank you
so cytosensei he he said um
this is a hombu technique
because you can't lift your arm up when
somebody is strong
so let's uh where's danny
so
we go backwards to go forward so i put
my arm up here he comes he takes it down
we come around here what do i do i try
and
now lift my arms up
in kina nagari
i can do it
as long as i exchange my body for my arm
if i go here and it comes around here
when it's down here there's no
there's no way you can bring that arm
higher anymore
hence that's why i use the string method
because
you've got a chance you've got a small
window
here's the window
to get the technique
so this
this
means that once the
point is chosen
it cannot alter
ah but i could redirect him
what with strength
i'll get you
i'll do it somehow
you know so
so if you want to do this technique
you have to do it quick
if you go if you do this technique
forget that one i've just done they're
down there
do
this technique
all right so in your toolbox we've all
got a toolbox and as we get
over the years we get
a better spanner and we give the
apprentice
the the cheaper spanners that we bought
when we were apprentice but we've stuck
to the job
i want the
more shinier the better ones as we get
better
we will start to get things that perhaps
bend a little to get into special places
and that's really what you're doing
going through the grades
you're you're saying
yeah but i can do this
so why should i improve on it i remember
teaching at um your seminar one night
and i said to this black belt
you can't do that
it works for me he said
i've
i i thought i i i
i thought i won't say no more to him
then because he's obviously got his
aikido
worked out so why did it take 20 years
for me to exchange strength
to coke you you can take coke you but
really it's common sense
well i can't do that well what you're
going to do well i'm trying to do the
technique well
that technique's not available today you
know
you've got to do you've got to do
something else
so
i know i'm sort of throwing you these
different techniques but i'm trying to
obviously get to a pattern of here
you've got a chance
of doing
lots of techniques
but not
not that technique anymore or not that
technique anymore
uh
the body can only do so many things and
if you've been watching the olympics
these wonderful ice skaters you'll
notice that you know the way they sort
of like cross over their legs and skate
this technique here
is like that as he comes i cross over
to get to the other side of his body
so those of you are wearing the hakama
you should
learn
one
two right you need to get across the
line you can't just sort of walk around
here because he'll pin this arm
so this hand and this opposite foot
makes it so you get out the other side
too late
i'll drop it down because that's where
he wants to push me
so i know i'm giving you too much
information but
so so here
cross the legs
here cross the legs
you can do whatever technique you know
if you don't know any techniques
if you get the leg part correct
you can perhaps
work some techniques
okay so i'm showing you ikea and sankyo
is that enough information let's try